und was sollen wir die türen aufmachen
[Musik]
guten abend meine lieben villiger bei
dir ist und herzlich willkommen zu einem
kleinen eigentlich kann man es nicht
bestraft das video nennen weil ich habe
ja in der top5 minecraft adventure maps
vorstellung sagt wenn das video 5000
daumen hoch bekommt spiele ich diese
minecraft 59 freddys map ich will das
extra an minecraft und nicht in echt
also nicht es gibt da von dir ein echtes
spiel das heißt freddys mal dass
mittlerweile auch schon sehr viele
gespielt und bei mir ist es so ich hasse
alles was irgendwie horror im namen
trägt und ich mache dabei sohn die hosen
und ich kann so was gar nicht spielen
in minecraft ist das ein bisschen
abgeflacht das ist nicht allzu krass der
horror aber es ist bei mir jetzt halt
auch gerade schon mitten in der nacht
und ich hab mir trotzdem hat die softbox
an damit ihr mich überhaupt irgendwie
sehen könnte eine face camp und deswegen
werde ich halt total geblendet von
dieser softbox ihr seht das ja wie krass
beleuchtet ich bin wahrscheinlich mache
ich alles schwarz weiß und so deswegen
ist das relativ dunkel alles in
minecraft aber ich werde das heller
machen dass ihr sehen könnt nur falls
ihr tue man sieht doch schon alles da
bleib ich sehe das nicht für mich ist
das anders hier total das blendet alles
weil ich ja ich muss mich ja ihnen
gesehen können und ich würde sagen wir
stiften erstmal und drücken ihr den
knopf und jetzt seht ihr schon was
passiert und zwar klingt gleich ein
telefon
da ist das telefon und zwar sind wir auf
einer jobsuche noch mal kurz pause damit
ihr das wir warten mal damit ich euch
das mal sagen kann wir sind hier auf
einer jobsuche
also wir als minecraft figur und wir
haben einen job bei freddy spitze
angenommen als nacht werte also wir sind
jetzt nachts in diesem pizza laden drin
und müssen wir gucken dass alles glatt
läuft und das alles vernünftig zugeht
weil in diesem pizza salaten passieren
komische dinge da sind zum beispiel ein
paar puppen die nachts aktiv werden mehr
oder weniger ist ein bisschen wie nachts
im museum das da diese leute müssen
aktiv werden diese alten aus stahl
stücke hier sind die puppen und die
wollen uns nichts gutes sondern die
wollen uns umbringen
und wir haben so ein kleines tablet das
zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal
wir haben ja so ein kleines tablet er
geht jetzt gleich ans telefon dran ich
hab das da von jeannette ein paar videos
gesehen also nicht von minecraft sondern
von dem spiel an sich und wir können
jetzt auf show stage klicken dann sehen
wir hier das da diese monster sind das
quasi diese stage also wo diese punkten
rumsitzen dann haben wir die dining area
dann haben wir den rest room haben wir
backstage friedhof kitchen haben wir nur
audio supply closet da sehe ich jetzt
wieder also dass das sehe ich wirklich
das ist heute wahrscheinlich extrem hell
und diese restlichen sachen sich halt
auch das sind diese gänge neben mir das
ist die beste
ist raul und israel corner aber was
quasi für uns ganz wichtig ist ist der
security office weil wir drin sind wir
jedoch niemand kommen hier können wir
sagen okay ich möchte mal hallo ich
möchte dass die tür für die zu der rest
all zugeht ok immer wieder auf ich kann
dass die tür zu dieser seite zu gehen
dann geht es wieder auf der zum beispiel
jemand ist dann kann ich auch mal nicht
am macherin schauen dass das packt immer
noch ein bisschen da ich auch nicht dann
machen und dann sehen ob da jemand ist
und hier kann ich auch mal ich dann
machen und dann kann ich das nicht auch
wieder aufmachen ich lasse ist jetzt
erstmal alles so und es bewegt sich
quasi alles um uns herum wenn wir
einfach so sind und wenn wir allerdings
hier mal schauen dann bewegt sich nichts
also ich sehe jetzt hier nur diesen
umriss von dieser person mehr sehe ich
hier nicht weil das für mich relativ
blendet aber ich kann es halt nicht
anders aufnehmen
deswegen kann ich erzählt schwer
erkennen ob da wirklich leute sind da
wirklich die alle noch in dem stage drin
sind das was er uns sagt dass quasi
nicht wichtig er sagt halt nur dass ein
schildermast das ist das schon okay was
soll eigentlich sollte noch niemand bei
uns direkt an der wand sein okay gut
noch ein bisschen an die sache ist auch
dass wir quasi mehrere nicht überleben
müssen das heißt also fünf nächte ich
spiele aber ding aber nur eine nacht
weil ich habe auch gesagt dass das ganze
dann ob ich meinen hut wirken soll
und spielt die erste nacht einfach durch
wenn ihr dann schauen was danach
passiert weil die erste nacht das noch
relativ relativ wie vorhin im test habe
ich auch schon die ersten acht verkackt
ich habe rating was bewegen gehört
er ist einfach direkt bei west hall
corner
heute bin ich aus senden
was fällt ihnen ein er ist direkt bei
mir doch erstmal zu in die usa da müsste
der irgendwo sein da vorne müsste wer
direkt stehen alter das ich jetzt gar
kein doktor werden jetzt auf einen
außenposten hier kommt damit ich habe
mir am arsch
ok erst in der westhofener jetzt wird
hier interessant das ist jetzt nämlich
echt also man muss die netten die nacht
überleben und ich würde gerne mal sehen
wo ich sehe wie spät es überhaupt ist
weil alle da war schon wieder gerade
irgendwas kurz eingeblendet
ok bye bye bye bye stage ich erkenne gar
nix eventuell sind da noch leute für
mich ist relativ hell alles dunkel ok
keine als im rest room sehe ich hier
gerade oder dass es so eine ausgestopfte
dings ok erst in der weströhre corner
ich hab schon wieder etwas bewegen
gehört okay er bleibt der rekorder
er ist quasi hier ist eben nicht mehr
oder weniger er ist quasi direkt an mir
dran und meine also meine energie muss
ich mir als so einteilen dass ich die
ganze nacht damit überall deswegen
brauche ich eventuell mal irgendeine
uhrzeit
wo soll ich denn hier wie spät es ist
es ist die uhr nie was ist das da
überhaupt
ich mache jetzt mal nicht
jeder ist niemand die tür hier
verbraucht extrem viel energie ich
möchte einfach mal dass dieser typ
lübeck geht aus der obersten corner
weil ich muss die tür quasi zu lassen
nicht dass er dadurch kommt oder so aber
die tür verbracht extrem viel energie
und ich möchte wissen wie spät es ist
wo kann ich denn sehen ich sehe ihn
nichts freunde ich würde euch am
liebsten man vor so dass man machen
freut sich dann in die kommentare
schreiben
man sieht doch anders jetzt macht dieser
ausgestopfte person da backstage
fahrradkauf kitchen supply co sydney wo
es toll corner ist es junge wie es
entstand in der israel korea ist das
denn deren ernst ich kann doch jetzt nur
beide türen zu machen weil ich wieder
raus hier
das kann doch jetzt nicht sagen der
eigenes in der east vollkorn und anderes
an der west hall corner ist das denn der
ernst die scheiße bin ich denn ok ruhig
bleiben erst mal ruhe finden
also ich bin jetzt so lange sicher die
touren die thüringer sind zu wir können
jetzt erst mal überlegen wo ist denn
hier nur ich sehe eher rechts und die
power usage und die geht so schnell
runter 38 37 ich kann doch nichts machen
was soll ich denn machen freunde ist
toll ist voll corner
ich würde hier nie arbeiten wollen alle
meinen jetzt das spiel das viel krasser
ich war jetzt aber für mich ist jetzt
leider auch schon ein ruhiges herz meine
power ist so um ein
ich frag einfach direkt die erste nacht
ich wollte das gar nicht spielen ich hab
gedacht ich schaff das nie mit den
daumen hoch power usage alter die geht
runter wie sonst was sollen wir die
türen aufmachen
das hätte ich doch nie gedacht also mann
ich sagen jetzt so als fazit vom hocker
faktor also es ist zwischendurch man
erschrickt sich nun sony das ist so die
ganze zeit so immer so anspannung so ein
bisschen aber sonst nichts aber dann
auch so ganz plötzlich kommt einfach so
ein typ verein und ich habe ja den ton
auf ganz laut und es hat einfach so der
horror effekt dass ich direkt das in den
kopf bekommen habe also freunde game
over ihr seht schon ich würde sagen das
war's ich sage jetzt ganz unmenschlich
pc millionen daumen hoch würde ich das
kannst du nicht spielen
ich habe davon nur videos gesehen und es
ist so krank also ich weiss nicht mehr
ich hasse ich will dieses spiel mich
verarschen jetzt kommt dass da noch mal
dieses monster freunde ich gehe hier
raus dann kann mir das gar nichts mehr
also es ist ganz cool gemacht nur es ist
extrem dunkel wenn ihr selber mal
spielen wollt ihr findet den link in der
beschreibung da ist auch das download
der ist der download bei und auch der
ist das resort spa event könnt ihr dann
nachvollziehen dass ich da teilweise
echt nichts gesehen habe ich finde es
ein bisschen schade dass man keine uhr
hat oder eventuell hat man ja nur ich
habe sie einfach nicht gefunden aber es
ist halt wirklich gerade es ist vier uhr
nachts gerade ich spiele das ganze ist
es stockfinster ich hab nur die softbox
an und da hinten sondern kann das licht
was immer anders wenn die softbox
irgendwie auch alles weil das so mit dem
stromkreis verbunden ist
ich fühle mich für mich ich habe ein
schwaches herz für mich ist das schon zu
viel
ich würde trotzdem sagen wenn es euch
trotzdem gefallen hat freunde dann zeigt
der winter mit härtung und ich mache nie
wiederhole